the big problem and we have a few
problems but like one major problem is
that were guided almost solely by GDP
stock market prices and profitability
and the issue is that with AI and new
technologies those things are just gonna
keep on going up and up
well not the stock where I mean it's
talking eventually it's not gonna stop
going up but GDP is gonna keep going up
even as more and more Americans get
displaced you know I mean if you have
like trucks magically drive themselves
that's like a boon to GDP because you
can get the same work done without
having to spend all this money on
cupid's but is that going to be good for
human wellbeing and a lot of communities
it's gonna be devastating for human
wellbeing so we need new measurements
that actually correspond to human
well-being
things like median income and wealth
levels of engagement with work mental
health and freedom from substance abuse
childhood success rates
yeah environmental quality proportion of
elderly and quality situations so you
can map these things and say hey like we
need to start driving our economy
towards human wellbeing we need to make
the market serve us as opposed to having
us all serve the market because if it's
us all serving the market we are going
to be screwed because the market is
going to zero out the truck drivers it's
going to zero out the count's it's going
to zero out a lot of people upcoming AI
is just now hitting a point where it's
going to be able to assume the roles of
hundreds of thousands of call center
workers and bookkeepers and a lot of
other things that we have a lot of
people doing right now so the so we need
to have new measurements for the economy
that correspond to our well being and
then start driving in that direction and
the great thing here is that this free
up these corporations to start doing
things that help people right now I know
CEOs and board members and they say my
hands are tied because I must optimize
for one variable like shareholder yeah
quarterly profitability shareholder
value like which are tied together so if
there's something else I can maybe get
away with it like one quarter if things
are going really well I can like do
something on the side and be like it was
good PR so we need to fundamentally
change the way that the goalposts are
set up
if we want to reorient towards an
economy that will serve us in what is
again the greatest technological shift
in human history yeah the real lining of
the goalposts is like right now this
rock is so small it just takes 40 days
to sail around this rock and the
geopolitical leadership is kind of
overthrowing though we are one mentality
and the prioritization of markets is
overthrowing the humanity yes and these
things being paired together they're
making the goal posts about money and
about geopolitical leadership and
ownership and and and and control and
things like that which I think a lot of
people are racing towards but at the
same time it's putting a back seat on
humanity putting a back seat on the
mentality of shifting the goalposts a
little bit towards humanity what would
that do how would that change the world
for us and you know you're also working
on a digital Social Credit in that
direction as well which you know this is
another really cool pillar it acts as
kind of you know you're doing some token
ah mcc's here well so you have to look
at the issues on the ground because the
startup guy I'm always like okay there's
like the stuff in the boardroom and the
you know the whiteboard and then it's
like what's happening on the ground so
what's happening on the ground right now
is that again more and more American men
are leaving the workforce and men tend
to deteriorate it without work we
include myself because I you know I'm a
guy and I resemble this the first thing
we tend to do is play a lot of video
games so except 5% of this now freed up
time goes to video again this is like a
lost meaning or purpose in life so now
what do we turn to yeah just an idle
dude like the the progression seems to
go by the numbers because I'm a very
data-driven guy it's a lot of video
games which works well in your 20s but
then you start getting sad in your 30s
and then when you start getting sad in
your 30s you go draw it all itself start
to be you know like violence and
criminality and early death that's like
the the general progression without work
sounds [ __ ] horrible by the numbers
this different situation for men and
women idle women do not disintegrate
into antisocial behaviors in the same
ways
you have to look at like the ground
floor and say okay hundreds of thousands
of former truck drivers who now you're
sick okay here's some money but that
doesn't sound problem of what what you
do all day because people need structure
fulfillment here piss work so if we say
to the market being like hey market like
value these people it's going to be very
very difficult because the markets like
I don't really need these people like at
least the way the monetary-market the
way the monetary-market so so we have to
do is if you have these new goals for
the economy then you can say you know
what if you nurture a child volunteering
the community help your neighbor give
someone a ride repair a boiler like any
of those things that move move the
society's goalposts along like install
solar panels work at infrastructure then
we're going to reward you time banking
time banking yeah it's based on the
system called time banking that's in
effect in a couple hundred communities
around the country where if you do
something for someone then you get a
time dollar and then you can say hey I
got this time now I can give it to you
and then you have to do something for me
and then people someone's like okay so
you create all these touch points in the
economy that are independent of skill
level that it's just like anyone can
show up and staff your garage sale or
babysit your kid you know like they're
different things that people can do and
then you tokenize those activities you
guarantee it and as president I will do
this in 2021 you guarantee a monetary
value and you say look these tokens have
real value like you bring them to a bank
will give you a dollar for every like
ten social credits but the beauty of it
then is that you will tax their
Redemption and so people will not redeem
it very often they'll what they'll do is
they'll just build social credits and
then they'll use the social credits with
each other they'll go to businesses that
will be rewarding positive behavior and
want to be seen as like hey like you
know we love it when people volunteer in
the community so if you come here social
credits and then they get your credits
and trade it to the government all these
things that can be done and you can
build this parallel economy around
pro-social activities that's accessible
for people and at every point the skill
ladder that is the vision yeah that's
what we have to go because if we listen
to the monetary market for too long
they're not going to
value these things like volunteering and
there I'm gonna value hi kid taking care
of kids taking care of elderly my wife
right now is home with our two boys who
are five and two she works harder than I
do
and about the market value of her work
is zero zero you know yeah and well I
guess technically if you had to hire
somebody else to take care of your two
kids during that time the market value
of that would be thirty fifty bucks an
hour or whatever for two kids yeah I
mean you could get nannies and and
whatnot though you know there is a
difference yeah and you know there are
many things to they're similar like if
you you know if you and if you look at
the way like the market values for
example home health care aids like
taking care of your aging parent you'd
be like oh I could pay someone to do
that right now the market rate for that
is twenty two thousand dollars a year
and there's a turnover one hundred
percent like pretty much no one wants to
do that job of taking care of the
elderly where because we remunerated at
very very low levels and so what's
happening in a lot of these contexts is
you look at it and the market tries to
seek like the lowest price point that it
can get away with because you know and
and but that causes its own set of
problems and friction so the the goal
for us has to be to invigorate some of
these activities for a couple of reasons
one we need them because our society is
disintegrating like as we're sitting
here were force participation down our
life expectancy has declined for the
last two years because of a surge in
suicides and drug overdoses or seven
Americans are dying of opiates every
this mental health shit's crazy yeah and
it's gonna get worse if we don't figure
out the automation how we yes it's all
tied together yes where you have
Americans getting pushed into this
mindset of scarcity where they don't
have the bandwidth process things
rationally and then they become more
impulsive they make lesser decisions
they get angrier and more like you know
xenophobic and and and the rest of it I
mean if this sounds familiar this is
exactly what we're going through right
now this is a giant automation story and
so we have to start owning the problem
and then have real solutions that are
going to be massive
that's the generational challenge but
that's why I'm running for president to
galvanize energy
around real solutions instead of the the
garbage stopgaps that are being
presented